Chief fire officer and somebody is not coming out and welcome to the show.
Welcome.
[Inaudible].
We have to talk about your exceptional story. Uh,
I mean, how you became what you are today, but, but first of all,
try to describe for me, if I, if I were to walk with you, uh,
into, uh, a fire in a house, I was dressed for it.
What would I experience?
You know, it's interesting because with firefighters,
firefighters are running in when every human instinct is to run out.
So we train a lot. So we're prepared when we go into that kind of environment.
But if I can help you to imagine it,
not just from the perspective of the firefighter,
but from the perspective of the person that's trapped inside,
that needs us to go and help.
And what they'll be experiencing is darkness because the smoke comes
down very, very low. So it's very difficult to see for a firefighter.
We can't see in front of our mask, we can't see our hands, nothing.
So all of your senses are taken away.
You can't hear anything because you've got the breathing apparatus on and all
you can really hear is the noise from that, or the noise from the fire.
You can't smell anything because we have the mask that's covering our face so
that we can breathe air.
But then what you feel is the heat and the heat can be extremely intense.
So you imagine a situation where all of your senses are taken away from you.
It's hot and it's uncomfortable,
but you have to push on because you know that there's somebody in there that
doesn't have the same protection that we do. Who's relying on you.
And you're the only thing standing between helping them to go out and be with
their family and their loved ones and have another normal day or that being the
end.
Is it noisy?
Uh, it can be because the, the fire can be very noisy depending on where it is.
It can be quite crackling.
But the other thing that's very noisy for us when we're in,
there is our breathing operator sets because you hear the constant hiss of air.
So it can be quite difficult to communicate as well. Plus you've got the diving.
It's exactly that. Yeah, exactly. That, but.
What is it? Is it, is it, is it chaotic?
Is it a feeling of chaos?
Um, I wouldn't say it's chaotic. Um,
I think there's order within it,
but I think normality is removed for that period.
So it's an incredibly challenging environment.
And the other thing that you experienced,
depending on how you're coping with the situation,
you can experience some quite extreme set stress.
And when you experienced stress,
it reduces the processing capacity in your brain.
So what we find is you can be very focused on the here and now,
but not necessarily anticipating what might come next.
So how, how would, would your mindset be as, uh,
as a trained a firefighting, how the mindset be when you go in there,
it would be incredibly.
Focused. We train incredibly hard.
So in terms of our processes and procedure, they're drilled into you,
like it's second nature. So from that perspective,
you do what you're trained to do,
but the biggest part for us is the empathy that you feel for whoever is relying
on you to be in there. And I tell you,
there is no bigger driver for us, I think,
than experiencing the loss from the perspective of the people outside.
Because when you see that human face of hope, just ever way,
when you come out empty handed,
there is no bigger driver for going back in or making sure that you don't come
out empty handed next time. And actually,
I have to say that I so admire the courage of you and your sister
having experienced the loss that you have and talking about it.
So openly with such courage helps so many other people who've been in a similar
position. So, so thank you for your strength.
[Inaudible], uh, your PhD is about this stress,
this the, the, the,
the challenge of making the sessions in stressful situations,
uh, and it was important for you to study this on your, your study has been,
uh, international air claimed and,
and a very important tool for firefighters all over the world. Um, and I,
I wonder, uh, what, what happens with us? I mean,
in stressful situations, how are our abilities limited?
Well, it's interesting, you know, because when we started doing this,
this research, so this was kind of all after the PhD,
we started to do some research all across the UK,
and it was the first time we'd ever been able to do research at an incident
ground because I was a firefighter first, before I studied this.
So you can kind of go into the dangerous environments that typically scientists
can't go into. It's like, Oh, I know I'm a scientist. It's like, no, not here.
You're not bait. So off you go.
So we were quite fortunate from that perspective. Um,
so we were able to collect data from the scene of operations and what we
discovered was absolutely revolutionary.
We found that when we're making decisions in that kind of an environment,
80% of the time, we're making guts, intuitive decisions,
we're not balancing all of the different options.
And coming up with an analytical decision, it's a gut decision.
We're responding based on our experience, our, what,
it might be a particular cue in the environment, but critically for us,
we were taking one piece of the jigsaw and reacting to that rather than putting
it into the big picture. Now,
I know from experience that if you're not thinking about the big picture,
and if you haven't got that really clear picture of what's going on,
people can get hurt.
And I had some personal experience of that when my husband and I were both
firefighters together,
and one day I was called to an incident where a firefighter had been very
severely burned and there was a one in four chance that it was him.
And it was the most difficult experience I'd ever had. Because for me,
I was completely torn between the role of a responder and all of the
accountability that comes with it,
and the role of a loved one and all of the human emotion and fear and an
anticipation that came with that. Now,
I was really fortunate because it wasn't him that was burned,
but it was our friend. And as much as I felt this massive sense of relief,
I also felt this huge sense of guilt,
because I felt like by not wanting it to be him, I'd wished it on somebody else.
And so this was the driver for the research,
because we know actually that 80% of the time when people get injured,
it's because of human error,
not a problem with your equipment or a flawed policy or, or a rubbish procedure,
but a human mistake. And that means people were getting hurt.
A human mistake in a stressful situation.
Exactly that. So with the research,
we were looking at the kind of stressful environment where people could make
mistakes to try to understand the human more so we could reduce human error
and actually what we were then able to develop with some techniques that could
help firefighters make better decisions and keep them safer and help them to
move past that single piece of the jigsaw and slot it back into the big picture
and make a decision based on that.
Are you saying that bravery is something you can teach and learn?
So it's bravery is an interesting words because the thing about
bravery people assume that I think bravery is kind of fearlessness, right?
You're not afraid of something. And I think it's the opposite.
I think if you're being exactly that you are afraid of something,
but you do it anyway. And that's brave instinct for,
I think it's like a mindset it's recognizing the fear,
but seeing your pathway through that.
So good assess control your feelings.
[inaudible] talk about choosing. Yeah. You can't,
you can't escape fear when you're standing there and everything that the
building is falling down, you know,
but you can choose how to deal with that fear.
And that's something you can train. Yeah. Right. So tell me,
who do you become in a stressful situation?
Well, it depends on in stressful situations.
I'm quite hysterical and I have four kids.
So my biggest nightmare is that something should happen to them, of course.
But when things happen, when it's people around me always screamed,
like help do something, do something.
And I like put my everything on other people.
Have you been in such a sensitive situation? And I told myself,
if something happens to my kids, when I'm alone, they're going to die. I don't,
I'm not going to know what to do. I'm going to like last and screaming.
And then when my youngest daughter was one year, uh,
she got food stuck in her throat.
And that's the most thing that I could ever imagine happen.
And I saw her and I was alone with them, her and her bigger sister live.
And I just heard a strange noise from the table.
And it should puts like a big noxious ships in her, in her throat.
And then I was totally calm. I was, I had so much fear inside me,
but it was like, okay. And everything that I knew that I had to do,
I did it, everything.
I took her up and I did the thing between her shoulders. Nothing happened.
I did, I did everything, but it was really stuck. And I always had like,
hate melon fingers through the pain.
I did that pain. That's a wall. Uh.
That's a wall. And you don't see any hope from it. That's when you're stuck.
Yeah. But I mean, I always thought that I was going to be like, paralyzed.
What did I say? The parallel happened to her,
her eyes turned around and take it just white. And she was blue.
She was that she was just hanging. The thing was still sucks up,
put my long fingers down the throat. And I felt the thing.
And I like put it on amazing. Pulled it up.
And it came blood and she was still gone. And it was just like,
my child was dying and then she just took a breath.
But she has been long for many minutes. Yeah. Uh,
when the ambulance came and I was sitting in the ambulance and she was crying
and got her color back, Oh my God, I have one more child.
She still at the table sits in there. How old is she?
Then she was three and a half. So I had to call my neighbor,
my other child so that it wasn't so good in distress. I saved my small one.
[inaudible] more hysterical, but I was totally called and did everything right.
And the doctor said, did everything writes amazing? It was amazing. I was like,
I, it was amazing. Tell me.
Can I say something? They're like what Sabrina said,
train people. There's so much training equipment,
everything they know what to do. The training is intense. I've seen those.
I've been through those am very involved with the forces in India.
The training is so intense, but still when the real thing happens,
even among soldiers, nearly 60% of them will do all the wrong things.
Only 30 to 40% do what they have to do.
It's because of that situations are saved.
But those 60% will do all the wrong things because somewhere we
believe human emotions are already there. No, we are creating them.
It's up to us. Like she said, in one situation,
she is freaking in another situations. She somehow meant in the balance.
Once the balance was there,
your competent is at a different level of what any doctor could do.
You just did without the same level of training, just with information,
probably not with training. So about all balance. If there is no balance,
your own intelligence turns against you. So what you think is fear,
what you think is anger. What do you think is stress? Tension.
Misery is just one thing. Your intelligence has turned against you.
Once your intelligence has turned against you. There is no hope.
Can you relate to that?
I can actually. I mean, it's interesting what you say, and I agree with you.
And that's why for me,
the best training is when you're in an environment that will elicit that emotion
that you know, will be there in the situation that you need to use it in.
Because decision making for me is like a skill. It's like any kind of skill.
You have to train it in the environment that you're going to use it. I mean,
if you want it to swim the channel, if you wanted to swim in the sea,
then you wouldn't practice in a swimming pool. It's the same skill, right?
It's swimming, but you're using it in a different context.
So you have to train in the environment that will elicit all of those pressures.
So realistic training for me is just so incredibly important.
How much, how much training is,
how relevant is the fact that you have lived on the streets?
How, what does that give you as a firefighter?
Um, that's a really good question. And I think for me,
it has certainly formed the way that I view things.
And I think in many respects, it affected the way that I make decisions.
Because one of the things that I'd experienced when I was sleeping rough was a
sense of hyper-vigilance because you know, that there's danger everywhere.
So you're constantly looking for danger. So you become hypervigilant.
Now it's a bit thing because you're constantly looking around for stuff and you
can catch things before they happen.
But the downside is it can make you quite anxious sometimes,
but it has got better over the years.
But what I find is there've been a number of occasions when I've been in charge
of large incidents, and there's been a very, very small change,
like a change in wind direction.
And because I'm constantly looking out for stuff,
I've noticed it and we've been able to change the tactics and the situation has
changed for the better.
So I always try to see a positive and I know it might be hard to think that
there could be a positive from kind of experiencing something like homelessness.
And I'll be honest with you. It's a pretty crap time. Um,
but actually it is all part of who you are and how it forms you.
And I found it incredibly hard to talk about it's taken me,
I'll be honest. It's taken me about 20 years to find the courage,
to speak to people about this. I used to wake up with cold sweats,
worrying that people would know about it. Um,
but I decided to start talking about it this year.
And the timing was strange because you think about, you know,
being a senior fire officer, and I'm a chief fire officer,
I've got my own fire brigade now. And you think, well,
actually you're supposed to be absolutely infallible. You know,
you're supposed to know what to do all the time.
There's got to be no vulnerability there.
And I was standing up in front of people and say, no, I'm vulnerable actually.
And this is why,
but I needed to do it because I know that there are still thousands of people
who are in the same place today that I was back then.
And I needed them to know that it doesn't have to define who you are because I
let it define me for a long time, but you don't have to.
And that for me was the most powerful piece that I could do with it. So yes,
it was hard. Yes. It's shaped me in many ways.
Probably many more than I realize,
but actually you can always make lemonade if you've got some lemons.
[Inaudible].
Why, I mean, what happened was that you, you came from,
you had quite a happy childhood, uh, as long as your father were alive.
And then when he died, everything changed.
That's it? Exactly. So he was diagnosed with a terminal brain tumor,
um, when I was about three years old and then he was,
he got progressively worse and he died.
Then when I was nine and my mother absolutely adored
him. They were, it, it was like you and Brianne.
[Inaudible].
Um, they honestly, they absolutely idolized each other. So when he died,
she found it incredibly difficult to cope and people deal with trauma in very
different ways. And for my mother,
she found it very difficult to deal with at all.
And she suffered terribly with her mental health.
And I think mental health is something that for a long time has had a huge
stigma.
And we haven't spoken openly enough about our experiences with this and how it
affects us and what my mother did was kind of closed the doors.
And I think it's fair to say that if somebody goes to war with their demons,
is everyone around them that gets hit by the shrapnel.
And that was certainly the case in our family and our business broke down and we
lived in abject poverty.
We had a social worker coming back and forth all the time.
I don't know how we didn't end up in the care system if I'm really honest,
but it was really tough.
And it got to a point where I couldn't do it there anymore.
And that's when I started to sleep rough when I was 15.
I wasn't quite 16 yet at the time. Um.
What do you mean by sleeping? Rough? How could that be?
So sleeping outside on the streets basically. Um,
and it was a better alternative to the experience that we were having at home.
W was it like, was it dangerous for you? Was it,
I mean, it's for a young woman sleeping on the streets, it's not a safe.
Relatively dangerous, incredibly dangerous.
I lost count of the amount of times that I got, uh,
beaten senseless by people.
There were times when I I'll give you an example, one day I,
and this is going to sound really sturdy, but bear with me.
I wanted to go to sleep somewhere light, cause I was just fed up at the Doppler.
So I chose to go to sleep in a subway because you have the lighting in there.
So I put my cardboard down. I had my, my sleeping bag and my little dog,
I had a stray dog, stray dog, stray human best of friends. It was great. Um,
and he would sleep in the bottom of my sleeping bag and I, I woke up,
it must've been maybe one or two o'clock in the morning. I don't know,
but I could feel my sleeping bag was, it felt warm and wet. And,
and initially I thought, Oh great. The dogs done something in here. Um,
but actually I could hear someone laughing, a drunk guy laughing,
and he was urinating on my sleeping bag.
And that was the most dehumanizing experience.
But see this guy really misjudged this because he didn't know how to dog down
there and you shouldn't wave things around and a dog and an angry dog.
And let's just say, I don't think it'd be winging on anyone anytime soon.
Um, but, but.
But the practicalities of that,
I had a sleeping bag that was soaked in some guy's urine.
I was 16 years old by this point and I was completely alone.
I had no other clothes.
I had no other sleeping bag and I just went and I sat in the middle of the town
center.
I pulled up my legs like this and I sat on a bench and I just cried for the
whole night until the sun came up the next day.
What can you do that from a practical sense? There was literally nothing.
It was really intensely difficult.
And you went to school right? All the time. Yeah.
I mean wouldn't pupils or teachers recognize you on the streets.
Well, it's interesting. One of the reasons I kept going to school, um,
only until I was 16. So it wasn't that long a period, um,
was because I didn't want to go into care because when you grow up in that kind
of environment, you're brought up to kind of mistrust or authority.
And for me care was some kind of, you know,
Dickensian kind of environment where I'd get girl like Oliver twist or
something. So I didn't want to go into case. So I hid it. But you know,
I was selling the big issue,
which is like a street magazine and people buy it for
excellent. So I was selling this and one of my teachers, so me,
he made eye contact with me and then he looked down and he crossed the.
Street to avoid me.
And I just cried because I knew then that actually nobody cares. I mean,
I look back now and I think, well,
maybe you just didn't have any change and he didn't know how to let me down
gently. But you know,
you think actually that's someone who is supposed to be a caregiver
and the impact that, that had on me at that time to be honest has never left me.
And I, I hope,
I hope that he reflects on that and he thinks more about the
impact that you can have on somebody else.
I hope you meet them and you can tell them that to his face.
I don't think I'd be very polite.
Do you have any siblings? Sorry.
Yeah, I have one brother. Um, he,
he left home not long after I did maybe a year or so later.
And he stayed with friends and your mom, did you get the help to do that?
Or I actually went back and cared for her for about
12 years afterwards. Cause she still suffers today with her mental health,
but she's seen your success and everything that happens.
And there's some bits,
some bits of the detail about how it all happened that I don't talk about
because I've processed it, but she hasn't.
And so I don't want her to be affected or to become worse.
She'll process it in her own time. I hope. Um,
but I moved away to London then and now my brother lives next door to her and he
looks after her. So all through everything people have said, you know,
how do you still have a relationship with her?
And that's what we all have our demons and our challenges.
And we deal with it in different ways. And yes,
it can have an impact on other people,
but she's still my mother and I'll never give up on her. I never.
Uh, Sabrina, you, you, uh, save money,
um, enough to get a place to live, uh,
from selling the big issue. Um,
and you were determined to become a firefighter. That was your dream.
I didn't want to become a police. You didn't want to become a social worker.
Didn't you trust them?
I wasn't very good with authority. I think for me, there's a,
there's a really practical thing here.
I think social workers are incredible and I didn't realize how good mine was
until at least 15 years after I last saw him with the police,
my experience with the police at the time.
Wasn't so great because you imagine you're sleeping in the doorway of a shot
because you have nowhere else to go and they're just doing their job.
I get that, but they'd move you along. And I think, well,
where am I going to go, mate? You know, seriously,
where can you move me along to,
I'm going to wait for you to go around the corner and I'm going to go back and
I'm going to find another doorway to sleep in this. Isn't helping the problem.
So I didn't have that great relationship with authority.
So I have an amazing relationship with police now. I think they're fantastic.
And they do an incredible job. The problem here was the fact that they were,
they had to enforce a law that was quite frankly a little bit silly. Um,
so.
But, but, uh, and I mean,
you applied for a lot of jobs to become a firefighter and, uh,
finally you got the chance, um,
and the rest is history. So to say, um, but was it, I mean,
there are so few female firefighters, uh,
here in England and even in Scandinavia. Yeah. Um, did you,
did you always feel, were you always seen as an asset, uh,
among the other 500?
So I think that it's, it differs at different stages. So I all in all,
I've had an incredible career and I've worked with some amazing, amazing people.
The early part of my career,
wasn't so positive when I first joined the fire service,
there were seven women and 1700 men. So I was very much in a minority.
Um, and I wasn't exactly welcomed with open arms for the first six months.
I wasn't allowed my own name. They called me something incredibly derogatory,
which I won't repeat. Um, you can Google it. It's really bad.
Um, and I had some really difficult times there and I,
I can honestly say,
and I thought long and hard about whether to speak about this,
but I've experienced sexual harassment in my time.
I have had unsolicited, very inappropriate pictures sent directly to my phone,
but in this guy's defense, it was a very small screen back in those days. Um,
being told that things have to be different for me because I'm a woman. Um,
so there have been some really challenging times,
but I'm going to caveat that by saying,
I've also worked with people who are still to this day. Like my big brothers,
I've worked with people who believed in me so strongly that I've been able to
do things that I never thought I was capable of doing and just had an incredible
career. So it's a very small part of my experience,
but it's important I think to talk about it because I didn't at the time because
I was young and I was insecure and I was afraid that the balance of power was
against me. And I think regardless of whatever industry you're in,
whether it's a professional perspective or a personal perspective,
we've all been in situations where the power relationships are such that we
haven't been able to express how we feel or say no to something or ask somebody
to stop what they're doing for, for fear of whatever. Um,
and I think it's important to open that discussion.
So your, um, you have adultery yourself.
Yeah. So will she become a firefighter as well?
I don't know. She at the moment she wants a dragon.
And so there's an interesting story here, so,
well, this is it. So, um,
game of Thrones has a very special place in our household.
So it's actually replaced cursing because I was, we have dogs, I love dogs.
And one day I was walking around and fell over the dog and I went,
Oh mother. And then I saw her walk in this cute little face.
I went mother dragons.
So now I'll be driving along in London and someone will cut in front of me and
there'll be this little voice from inside of me going dragons.
So at the moment I think she wants to, she wants to dragon.
So I take it. We are getting, I take it.
We are getting closer to selfie time. Thank you so much,
Sabrina. Nice. Thank you very much.
Hope you enjoyed the clip for more interesting conversations,
please hit subscribe.